una receta para pastelillos de plátano y
avena requiere tres cuartas partes de
una taza de avena tres cuartos de una
taza de avena prepararemos un medio o la
mitad de la receta cuanta ven ocuparemos
vamos a ver lo que vamos a hacer aquí es
multiplicar tres cuartos que es el
original de la receta por un medio que
sólo haremos la mitad de la receta por
lo que tendremos la multiplicación de
los numeradores 3 por 1
y la multiplicación de los denominadores
4 por 2 con esto tendremos tres octavos
y esta será nuestra respuesta nosotros
ocuparemos tres octavos de una taza de
avena pero como vamos a representar esto
o cómo podemos visualizarlo de una
manera mucho más gráfica pensemos en lo
siguiente tengo
es
digamos que esta charola
porque este bloque me representa el
total de una taza de arena
y vamos a dividirlo entonces en cuartos
porque tenemos nuestra receta original
en cuartos
esto será la mitad
ok
y tenemos nuestra taza dividida en
cuatro partes iguales vamos a considerar
este color magenta como el total de 4
nosotros para la receta original
necesitamos tres cuartos vamos a
colocarlo en color naranja tres cuartos
era uno dos tres marcar en
con esta línea naranja hasta donde será
para que tengamos un poquito más de
claridad entonces tendremos
uno dos tres de los cuartos
estarán para la receta original vamos
bien
y si me están diciendo que nosotros solo
prepararemos la mitad de la receta vamos
a marcar la entonces la mitad de esos
tres cuartos que es esta línea naranja o
estos tres bloques la mitad será
realmente esto
y marcaré una vez más
para tener más claridad de los colores
tenemos el total de la tasa tres cuartos
de la tasa y la mitad de tres cuartos
vamos a hacerlo esto para que vaya
quedando mucho más claro nosotros cómo
podemos saber que estos son tres octavos
tenemos la mitad si nosotros tomáramos
cada uno de estos cuatro
de estos 4 bloques 1 2 3 4 si nosotros
partiéramos cada uno de estos cuatro
bloques en dos tendríamos entonces 8
vamos a poner la separación aquí
tenemos una primera mitad 12
78 tendremos entonces
8 pedazos idénticos cuántos de ellos
estamos utilizando para la mitad de la
receta original pues estamos ocupando
este espacio en verde
este espacio en verde será uno
tres de los ocho espacios que hemos
colocado y es así como tiene sentido que
la mitad de tres cuartos o tres cuartos
por un medio sea igual a tres octavos lo
pudimos ver a través de las operaciones
y también a través de esta imagen donde
tenemos tres octavos obtuvimos tres
cuartas partes de la taza y sólo
elegimos la mitad para nuestra receta